I'll try not to be emotional about this
but I
I've heard uh Anthony fauci a couple of
times now say that he represents science
I know what he means by that he means in
the political bickering
all that kind of stuff that for a lot of
people he represents science
but words matter and this isn't Just
Clips I mean maybe I'm distinctly aware
of that doing this podcast like yeah I
talked for like hundreds of hours now
maybe over a thousand hours but like
I'm still careful with the words like
I'm trying not to be an [ __ ] and I'm
aware when I'm gonna ask when I'll
apologize for it
uh like if the words I represent science
left my mouth which they very well could
I would sure as hell be apologizing for
it and not enough because I got in
trouble I would just feel bad about
saying something like that and even that
little phrase I represent science
no Dr fauci you do not represent science
I love science the the millions of
scientists that inspired me to get into
it is to fall in love with the
scientific method in the
exploration of ideas through the
rigorous science that Anthony fauci does
not represent he's one I believe great
scientist of millions he does not
represent anybody uh he's just one
scientist and I think the greatness of a
scientist is best exemplified in
humility
because the scientific method basically
says like you're you're like standing
before the fog the mystery of it all and
like slowly chipping away at the mystery
and the it's like it's embarrassing it's
uh humiliating how little you know
that's the experience so the the great
scientists have to have humility to me
and especially in their communication
they have to have humility and I mean I
don't know and some of it is also Wars
matter because
you have to like great leaders have to
have the Poetry of action they have to
be bold and Inspire action across
millions of people
but you also have to
uh through that poetry of words Express
the complexity of the uncertainty you're
operating under be humble in the face of
not being able to predict the future or
understand the past or really know
what's the right thing to do but we have
to do something and through that you
have to
be a great leader that inspires action
and some of that is just words and he
chose words poorly I I mean I so I I'm
all torn about this and then there's
politicians they're taking those words
and magnifying them and playing games
with them and of course that's the
disincentive for the people who do the
the scientific leaders that step into
the Limelight
to say any more words so they kind of
become more conservative with the the
words they use I mean it just becomes a
giant mess but I think the solution
is to ignore all of that and to be
transparent to be honest to be
vulnerable and uh
the the express the full uncertainty of
the what you're operating under to
present all the possible the actions and
to be honest about the mistakes they're
made in the past I mean there's
something even if you're not directly
responsible for those mistakes taking
responsibility for them is uh is a way
to win people over like I don't think
leaders realize this often in in the
modern age in the internet age they can
see through your [ __ ] and it's
really inspiring when you take ownership
so to do the thought experiment like in
public do a thought experiment if there
was a lab leak and then lay out all the
funding the equal Health Alliance all
the
incredible signs going on at the uh
Wuhan Institute of virology and the NIH
lay out all the possible ethical
problems lay out all the possible
um
mistakes that could have been made and
say like this could have happened and if
this happened here's the best way to
respond to it and to prevent it in the
future and just lay all that complexity
out I mean I wish we would have uh
seen that and I have hope that
this conversation conversations like at
your work
and books on this topic will inspire
young people today when they become in
the Anthony fauci's role
to be much more transparent and much
more humble and all all those kinds of
things that this is just a relic of the
past when there's a person no offense to
me in a suit that has to stand up and
speak
with Clarity and certainty I mean that's
just the relic of the past is uh
it is my hope but do you mind if I ever
agree with a great deal of of what you
said and I and I it's it's really
unfortunate uh that our certainly the
Chinese government as I said before our
government
um wasn't as transparent as I feel they
should have been particularly in the
early days of the pandemic and
particularly with regard to the issue of
pandemic Origins I mean we know that
that Dr fauci was on calls with people
like
um Christian Anderson at Scripps and
others in those early days raising
questions is this an engineered virus
there were a lot of of questions and
it's kind of sad I mean as I mentioned
before I've I've been
um one I mean and certainly there were
were others but there weren't a lot of
us of the people who from the earliest
days of the pandemic were raising
questions about hey not so fast
um here and I and I launched my web
website on pandemic origins in April of
last year April 2020 it got a huge
amount of attention and actually my
friend Matt pottinger who is the Deputy
National Security advisor when he was
reaching out to people in the U.S
government and in Allied government
saying hey we should look into this the
what he was sending them was my website
it wasn't some U.S government
information and so by the way people
should still go to the website you keep
getting keep updating it and it's it's
an incredible resource well thank you
thank you jamiemensel.com
um and it's really unfortunate that our
governments and international
institutions for pretty much all of 2020
weren't doing their jobs of really
probing this issue people were hiding
behind this kind of false uh consensus
and and I'm critical of many people even
when I heard Francis Collins uh
interview with you I just felt well he
wasn't as balanced on the issue of of
covet Origins certainly Dr fauci could
have in his conversation with Rand Paul
it wasn't even a conversation but in
some process in the aftermath could have
laid things out a bit better he did say
and Francis Collins did say that we
don't know the origins and that was a
shift and we need to have an
investigation so now
um but having said all of that I do kind
of one I have tremendous respect for Dr
fauci for the work that he's done on HIV
AIDS I mean I have been vaccinated with
the moderna vaccine uh Dr fauci was a
big part of the story of getting us
these vaccines that have saved millions
and millions of of lives and so I I
don't think I mean there's a lot to this
story and then the second thing is it's
really hard to be a public health expert
because you have your mission is public
health and so and you have to if you are
leading with all of your uncertainty
um it's a really hard way to do things
and so like even now like if I go to CVS
and I and I get a Tylenol somebody has
done a calculation of how many people
will die from taking Tylenol and they
say well we can live with that and
that's why we have regulation and so all
of us are doing kind of summaries and
then we have people in public health who
are saying well we've summed it all up
and you should do X you should get your
kids you know vaccinated for measles you
should not drive your car at 100 miles
an hour you you should don't drink
lighter fluid whatever these these
things are and we want them to kind of
give us broad guidelines and yet now our
information world is so fragmented that
if you if you're not being honest about
something that something material
someone's going to find out and it's
going to undermine your credibility and
so I agree with you that that there is a
greater requirement for transparency now
maybe there always has been but there's
an even greater requirement for it now
because
people want to trust that you're
speaking honestly and that you're saying
well here's what I know and this is
based on what I know here are the
conclusions that I draw but if it's just
and and again I I don't I don't think
the words I'm science or whatever it was
are are the right words but if it's just
you know trust me because of who I am I
don't think that that flies anywhere
anymore